february is the month of love and
valentine's day is quickly approaching
dinner for two is on the menu but maybe
one of you is vegan and the other is
plant-based curious but afraid to commit
or you're both flexitarian foodies
looking forward to a quiet easy night on
cupid's day whatever your mood you've
got some options
a mouth-watering fair on valentine's day
may be easier than it seems just ask
powerhouse restaurant or pinky cole when
we talk about lovers day that is one of
the most important days of the year
because it's the one time that you
really get to show your loved one how
much you care about them and what better
way to do it than with vegan food here's
a bit of lovers day food inspiration i
partner with morningstar farms and
incognito to create the make it easy
campaign for valentine's day so food
shouldn't have to take much thought
right it should be stress free it should
be guilt free so the make it easy
campaign is just that pinkie shares
simple recipes that anyone could tackle
one of them is a sausage sweetie that's
a breakfast sandwich that you can have
in bed with your loved one and it
consists of the sausage vegan egg vegan
cheese on a hawaiian bun and the
irresistible
with chicken tenders kimchi and a
teriyaki mayo
on a slider bun that i promise you
tastes better than the real thing visit
morningstarfarms.com for even more
recipe ideas
i like that that's kind of a situation
at your home right because your wife is
vegan yeah she does vegan yeah for
certain diet restrictions i love that
one name incognito
morning star i've had is really good
i've enjoyed yeah that was good i know
that the chef the lady who was telling
the recipes her restaurant is good look
at that she had it on camera that
breakfast sausage